What's black and blue
and dead all over
this is a powder king prisoners to match so take
it easy sweetheart i've been trying to reach you
If this continues it won't be long before you've
nothing left i don't care what happens to me
you're not so different who are you under there
I'm vengeance
For some reason batman just always stood out it's
one of the major characters of the 20th century
and so many people connect it on such a
deep level and for so many different reasons
the first conversation i had with matt
about it i just knew there was something
radically different from anything
we'd seen in my movies before
I felt that we'd seen lots of origin stories
we'd seen things go further and further into
fantasy and i thought well one place we haven't
been is grounding it the way that year one does
to come right in to a young batman
not be an origin tale but refer to his origins
and shake into his core right from the beginning
there's a desperation to it he's really working
out this rage all the fights seem very personal
what's so wonderful about this world
is the exploration of the gray area
catwoman really wants to fight for those who
don't have someone else to fight for them
and that's where batman and her really connect
he wants to inflict his kind of justice he's
just compelled to do it there is no other option
Welcome back everyone this is my new
batman trailer video they released another
new trailer with slightly different footage and
then even more footage and behind the scenes
with matt reeves robert pattinson zoe kravitz all
talking about the movie what the story is about
and about their characters so we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos there's still a
couple of big dc fandom trailers for the upcoming
movies that i'm working on that'll post in the
next day or so but just starting at the beginning
of this and working your way through shot by shot
so this is a very different version of the trailer
with a couple different scenes mostly focusing on
the riddler's big riddles like the two big riddles
that you see in the trailer he repeats the riddle
what's black and blue and dead all over recut with
slightly different footage for different context
focusing more on footage of batman himself in a
bunch of different scenes in different parts
of the film and i think this footage sort of
confirms my theory about what this riddle is all
about that the answer to the riddle is batman
himself he's talking about batman himself because
physically he's black and blue like his body is
broken you see all the scars on his back but he's
also kind of dead inside as a person and also sort
of backing this up a lot of people think that the
riddler is also saying after this it's you in a
really creepy kind of way like confirming that he
is talking about batman is if he's answering his
own riddle either way the trailer really wants you
to think that the answer to the riddle is batman
himself this is a scene of the riddler banging the
walls inside his prison cell if you couldn't tell
the way they cut this trailer they're very careful
not to give you like a full frontal picture of the
riddler's face you only see him with his mask
on with the glasses on top of the mask like his
zodiac looking costume and when he doesn't have
his mask on you only see him from behind or you
see like a side shot of his head if you didn't
remember it's paul dano playing the riddler so
we all know what paul daniel looks like so it's
not a big surprise everything that the producers
the people behind the movie matt reeves robert
pattinson are talking about talk about them doing
a batman story playing up all the horror elements
behind the character that you see in some of
the darker comics so it's sort of like a darker
version of a batman trilogy that they're working
on and in service of that obviously i've made the
references to the zodiac killer inspiring this
version of the riddler but there are people who
have claimed to bend to test screenings confirming
some of these theories that the riddler in the
movie is kind of a jigsaw type of character like
if you remember the saw movies jigsaw creates
all these different traps that are meant to
kill different people in very karmic ways very
twisted karmic ways in all the people that he puts
in these traps are people who committed crimes in
real life so the riddler's kind of doing the same
thing in the movie where all the different
people that he's killing are corrupt people
they're either like really legit criminals like
mobsters or their corrupt government officials
like the mayor that he kills at the beginning of
the trailer this is also backed up by that giant
riddle that you see batman walking around then
like you see him without his shirt on walking
into the middle of the question mark here with all
these lines extending out to these different names
and they're different people that i've talked
about in my last trailer video so i'll link that
at the end of this down in the description below
but the idea is that the riddler creates all these
different traps batman has to solve them or these
different people will die like all the different
times that we've seen that footage of the mayor's
funeral with the person who walks up there with a
message to batman and a bomb that goes off so if
you see people talking about this batman movie if
it's kind of like a saw version of a batman movie
and riddler's kind of like jigsaw that's what that
means so when you see that scene of him with a
red flare from overhead it looks really badass
and you see all those people behind him that's him
going to investigate one of the other traps that
the riddler has set and these are the people
behind him are a bunch of the police officers
a little more clarification on this riddler trap
too so when it says savage here some of you also
pointed out that pete savage is actually
the name of the current police commissioner
before gordon at the beginning of the movie
so i think it's also implied that he is on the
take with carmine falcone or he is corrupt in
some way and sins of the father might also be
a reference to thomas wayne in the comics saving
carmine falcone's life once and that creating this
sort of association between the wayne family
and carmine falcone they're only adapting some
aspects of the long halloween but they get into
that at the beginning of the long halloween with
carmine not knowing that bruce wayne is batman but
trying to get bruce wayne really rich person to
put a lot of his money in mob controlled banks and
there's some of you that think that renewal is a
lie might have something to do with the gotham
city orphanage during the events of the film
when you see the footage of him at the mayor's
funeral outside as bruce wayne just wearing the
normal clothes standing next to his car there
the old classic corvette gordon has voice over
dialogue that says this is a powder keg then they
cut in batman answering him saying riddler is the
match that's just a reference to the current
state of gotham with what the riddler is doing
trying to incite people live streaming one of his
killings to set things off like killing the mayor
so it sounds like during the movie the public
is aware of the ticking clock the game that he's
playing with batman and all the potential victims
that will die if batman isn't successful in saving
them and solving the different riddles would you
like to play a game batman this is new footage of
catwoman following batman through the graveyard to
one of the entrances of the bat cave it seems like
i do love the idea that one of the entrances of
the bat cave takes him through the graveyard very
on brand for batman and if you didn't see some of
the other behind the scenes or you didn't notice
this small detail his bat cave during the movie is
actually in an abandoned subway terminal but it's
the wayne terminus so it's an abandoned subway
terminal that was built by one of his ancestors
at some point remember the waynes were actually
one of the founding families of gotham that go
back hundreds and hundreds of years there's
other footage of catwoman watching him just
beat the life out of a criminal like she's kind of
afraid of him like oh my god what's going on here
the idea during this movie and i talked about
this in my last video is that he doesn't really
distinguish between batman and bruce wayne there's
no playboy bruce wayne persona where he goes out
and acts like a rich fool to throw people off the
sense so they don't think that he might be batman
during the events of this movie this early in his
career year two he has no interest in being bruce
wayne he only wants to be batman so i think the
idea is that during the majority of the film he
will be in the batman costume or doing batman
things you will see like very little footage of
him actually being bruce wayne running around
at night when they're looking at the page with
all the different versions of the batman symbol
you'll actually notice if you slow this down and
you actually read the text this is batman's diary
that he's been keeping it's in his handwriting
and it's a journal that he's been keeping while
he was creating the batman character everything
about his life and what he's doing right now
because they actually had to create this for
the film like it actually exists now maybe they'll
publish a version of it as part of an art book for
the movie next year at some point then you have
matt reeves talking about wanting to do a batman
year one kind of movie without actually having
to do a year one movie thus he makes it year two
then robert pattinson talking about why batman
is so hardcore during the events of the movie
the reason why his fights are so personal
is just his desperation dealing with his own
personal trauma and just projecting that onto all
the criminals that he's going after every night
like while he's talking about this they also
splice in separate footage of a fight scene
with him beating a criminal with a baseball bat
like he's beating him with an inch of his life
there's a whole bunch of new catwoman footage
more of their early fight scene when he catches
her at a crime scene this is right out of the long
halloween this footage of gordon kicking open the
door seems like it's inside the cemetery and he's
kicking open the door to some family's mausoleum
there's also footage of batman taking gordon
in his batman costume into his garage where he
keeps all of his cars like you see all these
super expensive classic cars sitting around
then this last scene of him in the rain is the
trailer scene that we've all seen a billion times
of him saying i'm vengeance but if you spotted
any other really cool easter eggs in this brand
new footage that i didn't talk about during
the video just write them below in the comments
there'll be more trailers later this year early
next year as well the movie's coming out in march
speaking of versions of batman i just
did a video for the flash movie trailer
you can click here to watch that and click
here for my other new batman trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!